good evening my fellow americans
we've hired luther here to be my anger
translator
who killed osama bin laden god bless
america
stinker
all right
everybody focus up look
this party tonight could be a model for
the way that the world should work
and i just want to say
i'm totally stoked to the max about it
all right you guys feeling good oh yeah
oh
dennis what are you shooting video yeah
man all right well be careful with that
i might run for office someday
now trust me i think that this party can
be
the most inspirational party this campus
has ever seen is that coming to me
and just
grab that
[Music]
it's a brightest bug it's a righteous
belt we got going on there
we need some bodacious jock babes coming
in yeah we need some hot ass punk rock
babes
i i don't care where they come from the
most important thing it's imperative
that we have a diversity in the uh
uh [ __ ] department intercepted
don't sleep on barrio
don't ever sleep on barrio
that is some major dopage
[Applause]
[Music]
apartheid is totally gnarly
it's a gnarly institution where is he
dennis that there you go come here get
this get this okay we gotta have a
system in place to get everybody weed
all right so just watch this is how
you're gonna do it all right this this
i'm really
frosty right now by the way this is your
constitution all right it's just a piece
of paper we gotta keep its integrity
because it's gonna hold everything
together this right here
this is us this is the american people
we're special we're magic hello yay we
all live in here all right the most
important thing is that we don't get too
far apart me and you we got to be close
that's that's the magic of america's
love otherwise we're going to get air
bubbles in there it's going to start
canoeing and everything we don't want
that all right you get that all right
look
my way ahead of you but i'm already done
boom fireworks fourth of july that's for
you we want like ten of these
oh
my god i'm so fast
i'm so
oh what was i saying
when i roll down the street brothers all
take a knee honey's dropping their g's
run pieces of me cause i run this whole
block with these rhymes and this glide
make this whole damn hood tick this my
tongue i'm the toss cocking the
you know it's true
[Music]
i'm the leader of the free world
thank you and may god bless america
this is john o'rourke nice to meet you
mr ian roberts nice to meet peter tencio
all right nice to meet you
jerome smith come on
what's up fam
you know this keith williamson nice to
meet you mary woodbury nice to meet you
jay martel nice to meet you sir tasha
robinson come on come on come on
feel that emily george all right
nice to meet you daryl stokes come on
what's up fam how you doing
never forget about that cause that's all
we got
nice to meet you all
right bring it down bring it in
starting from the bottom now we're here
yeah
nice to meet you
all right nice to meet you all right
nice to meet you
1 8th black afternoon my octoroon come
on bring it in there
yeah i'm in there i'm in there i'm in
there you talking about it
i'm in there
you come in there
i'm in there all right nice to meet you
man uh nice to meet you oh my goodness
look at this oh
she is so beautiful um
i want another one there you go precious
beautiful beautiful what's her name oh
this is livia roojie okay nice to meet
you miss rougey
all right now come on
boom
all right very good to meet you all
right here we go right this way sir
now first let me just say that i'm
encouraged that so many of you from the
republican party have
agreed to meet me in this way
now as you know i've tried very hard to
reach across the aisle
and govern this country from the middle
well
all due respect mr president
we disagree with you
we think you should run the country from
not the middle
well that's why we're here
if you would i'd just appreciate some
feedback on some new ideas and
directions for this country feel free to
agree or disagree
whatever you want
we're gonna disagree
disagree
first
i think the government is too big
i think we need to shrink the size of
the federal government so that all
decisions can be made at the state level
we disagree mr president
you drive a hard bargain you win
[Laughter]
[Music]
there we go
[Laughter]
big government it is
next up
this has been a hot button issue but i
think we can settle it right here
no taxes
for rich people we completely disagree
round two goes to you guys
okay
more taxes for the rich
what the
what is happening to us and i am taking
a beating here guys all right last issue
immigration
now
we need to secure our borders
and anybody who's here illegally should
be hunted down and deported
[Music]
if we disagree
[Music]
we are a country of immigrants no
we need a clear path to citizenship for
all of those who are already here
[Music]
great i love your ideas lastly we cannot
regulate firearms
all right all right
you guys say so
nobody better throw me a cigarette
[Music]
ain't i a stinker
all right you're doing fine sweetie
now uh malia let's just go easy on the
gas here and come to a complete stop
okay so in the future you want to try
not to go through stop signs
okay just remain calm now and uh what
you're going to want to do is pull up
right here uh next to the curb
this is why we want to stay in the lines
and we want to follow rules
remember this
license and registration
holy
mr president yeah yeah just uh teaching
malia to drive
well you guys ran a stop sign back there
but that's okay you can go oh no no no
no well malia's got to learn what it's
like to drive in the real world here
well this is called consequences malia
now i want you to go ahead and treat us
like you would if i weren't the
president
not exactly what i had in mind oh come
on this is something i got my man's been
up 10 minutes okay the number pressing
no no just
hold on a second malia all right just
hold on
[Music]
sorry everyone it was
taking so long
obama obama how you doing sir
it's me
just showing my daughter how to use the
atm having a little trouble with the
machine oh you having trouble with the
machine oh man we tripping with you
right now man then you can be on your
way no no no no no no i'm trying to show
malia what life is like in the real
world here all right so just do me a
favor treat me like you would anyone
else in the situation okay yes sir yes
sir all right
hurry up man is your turn stuck in the
damn machine
not exactly what i have in mind
[Music]
come on girl hurry up man you got seven
oh okay take your time take your time
take your time
good evening my fellow americans
now before i begin
i just want to say that i know a lot of
people out there seem to think that i
don't get angry
that's just not true i get angry a lot
uh it's just that the way i express
passion is different from most
so just so there's no more confusion
we've hired luther here to be my anger
translator luther hi
first off concerning the recent
developments in the middle eastern
region i just want to reiterate our
unflinching support for all people and
their right to a democratic process hey
all y'all dictators out there keep
messing around and see what happens just
see what happens watch also
to the governments of iran and north
korea
uh we once again urge you to discontinue
your uranium enrichment program hey
mahmoud kim jong i think i already
untold both y'all 86 y [ __ ] i'ma come
over there and do it for y'all please
test me and see what happens on the
domestic front uh i just want to say to
my critics
i hear your voices and i'm aware of your
concerns so maybe if you can chill the
hell out for like a second then maybe i
can focus on some you know
that goes for everybody uh including
members of the tea party oh don't even
get me started on these muppets right
here i want to assure you that we will
be looking for new compromises with the
gop and the months ahead and you know
he's going to say no before i even
suggest him
now
i know
a lot of folks say that i haven't done a
good job at communicating my
accomplishments to the public because
y'all my don't listen uh
since being in office we've created
three million new jobs three million new
jobs we ended the war in iraq end of the
war y'all we ended a war remember that
these achievements should serve as a
reminder that i am on your side i am not
a muslim and that my intentions as your
president are coming from the right
place they're coming from hawaii which
is where i'm from which is in the united
states of america y'all okay this is
ridiculous i have a birth certificate i
have a birth certificate i have a hot
diggity doggity mama say my massamu
microsoft birth certificate your dumb
ass crackers okay luther yep roping yeah
dial it back luther damn in conclusion
uh last night i had a conversation with
michelle
nope i did not say that i did not say
that good evening my fellow americans
now before we begin
i'd like to once again introduce you to
my anger translator luther hi
now this november i want each and every
one of you to ask yourselves what has
changed in the last four years who
killed osama bin laden
what is my administration accomplished
did we accomplish killing america's
biggest enemy uh check did that boom
in 2011 alone we created more jobs than
george w bush did in all eight years of
his office except for osama bin laden
hunter because that job don't exist
anymore because i went over there and i
killed him in his face we helped make
health care accessible to more americans
than ever before i'm sorry what'd you
say uh your world trade center hurts
then why don't you take two dead bin
ladens and call me in the morning [ __ ]
this election
make the decision that you think best
serves the future of this country or you
can eat a dum-dum sandwich and just vote
for the person who didn't kill osama bin
laden why would you do it why would you
do it
i plan to run a clean campaign
one based on the issues and the
accomplishments of my administration but
i'm gonna tell you right now if the
republicans
if they get caught osama bin laden they
wouldn't even pay an election man they
just put a crawl on his head and give
him a castle and it's calling the king
of america and never me
all right all right all right just you
know bring it down a notch there
come on luther man you're straight up
out of control brother well uh it's not
that bad okay don't beat yourself up
it's okay
excuse me can i get a lozenge no luther
you you can't say that word oh
actually it says right here i can say it
whenever i want
i guess i can say it too
good
night good evening my fellow americans
now
first off i would like to once again
introduce my anger translator luther hi
now
in the spirit of democracy i would like
to take a moment to address my opponent
mitt romney ooh i've been waiting for
this
oh boy i've been waiting for this
what's up mitsubishi governor romney and
i have different ideas on how to best
help the american people i saved the
auto industry you want to give tax
breaks to millionaires i killed osama
bin laden and you strapped the dog to
the top of your car now let's see who's
better for the country i look forward to
a fruitful and healthy debate on the
affordable care act and since you
already did it in massachusetts it's
going to be real interesting to watch
your flip-flopping ass on your me on
that wow
but i also look forward to other ways to
articulate our differences i'm like the
mother love child of the old spice guy
and the dose equis dude
and you are literally the bulliest
whitest man alive today
i know that we will conduct professional
campaigns
now we will be respectful to one
another's personal lives families and
religion oh man come on i still got to
explain to half the country that i'm not
a muslim but it's still off limits to
talk about your moment as wearing magic
underwear and believing jesus came down
and did some
in pennsylvania
i mean this is some craziness luther
this but yes pennsylvania is a swing
state let's take it down or not
come on luther man why you always gotta
cross the line of good east man
i believe the american people will see
that i've made their lives better in the
past four years americans will all be
riding these violent save the auto
industry
i'm also confident that the american
people will make the choice that will
best help them and best help our path to
the future no no i'm winning this
thank you
and good night good evening my fellow
americans with me as always is my anger
translator luther hi now after the last
debate i was criticized for
not showing enough emotion i should have
been on that stage oh my god nick if i
was a siberian tiger your ass would have
been roy
right up
i was faulted for a lack of pithy
retorts or uh zingers
but we can do better than that witty
responses are not going to resolve this
nation's deficit how you gonna fire
sesame street one of those [ __ ]
already lives in a trash can zing and
the one-liner is not going to solve the
problems we have with our tax code which
my opponent seems to have entirely
changed his position on this
[ __ ] gets more reboots than
spider-man and boom goes a dynamite i
look forward to a debate based on
substance
not on zingers i got a mormon singer
take my wives please oh
that's their wives thank you and good
night this message brought to you by the
letter suck my and the number
oh
snap america
snapping deep good evening my fellow
americans with me as always is my anger
translator luther boom
i stumped your battleship [ __ ] what's
up
to the american people i just want to
say the debates are over but
now it's not a time to
tally points or to
keep the score 2-1 obama game set match
touchdown home run checkmate can we get
back to work now
governor romney in the recent debate i
laid out the inconsistencies in your
stated beliefs okay governor ron
i'm going to tell you you know governor
romney
why are you smiling while you're getting
your ass kicked are we debating or are
you trying to sell me a lexus i directly
questioned you uh about your opposition
to the auto industry bailout on behalf
of all the people in detroit that want
to stab you i asked again why are you
smiling
i asked you about your stance on syria
which you called iran's route to the sea
hey
dummy
look
iran is on the sea syria's two goddamn
countries this way
bam
which is a city in iran i even reminded
you that horses and bayonets are not
strategically valid in modern warfare so
like i said it's time to wipe that smug
smile off your sweaty sweaty pasty ass
sweaty face i mean mit do you need a
towel because your face is straight up
raining
i spoke about brinksmanship with iran
and you just said you wanted a peaceful
planet i mean who let wavy gravy up in
here i'm sorry man if you want to be the
first mormon hippie you're going to need
to grow your hair out dog
i quit smiling
there were many times where you even uh
inexplicably agreed with me stop
agreeing with me are you trying to body
snatch me and become me for the last two
weeks of the election i mean what's i'm
sorry time out sir i'm like legitimately
concerned that he's like an insane rich
crazy person uh who's gonna wait okay
yeah
calm down
all right i assure you governor romney
is not insane
okay thank you no problem in conclusion
i greatly appreciated our exchange on
foreign policy but we all know the only
country that matters is ohio you sweaty
smiley
never going to be president looking
mother
what hey
loosening up a little bit over here and
it's just about
time good evening my fellow americans
now as you know sometimes during the
chaos of a presidential campaign it's
easy to forget the beauty of the
democratic process
i mean y'all got to vote for me y'all
you have to or we're gonna get backed
over by a bunch of bitch-ass
millionaires
this is my anger translator luther who
i thought had the day off
what are you doing here
anyway
i think that everybody needs to take a
moment to appreciate
that our political system truly works
unless romney wins and then
is broke
and despite the heated rhetoric of a
campaign there's always a place for
civil discourse as long as you got a few
million dollars lying around so you can
counteract all the negative ads hey
romney and karl rove and all you evil
mother with your slimy ass super pacs
y'all done poker hornet's nest when i
shook a stick y'all slapped frankenstein
right
and you know what after i win this
i'm taking all y'all down
thank you and i'll see you all on the
campaign trail and when you give me your
babies to kiss please clean their
diapers all right cause i ain't trying
to kiss no poop
just wash their ass
you know just wash their ass
it's true
you should wash their ass
good evening my fellow americans i just
want to thank you for your continued
faith and my ability
we won
that's my anger translator luther wow
yeah what's up
but i want to wish my opponent mitt
romney well he ran a good campaign take
that [ __ ] back to the lab man cause you
lost
now we move forward with pressing issues
we're gonna pass health care again now
what [ __ ] while we had huge turnout
from our faithful supporters thank you
black folks we made it to two elections
in a row man now how hard was that all
your votes were crucial in this victory
white people who voted for me you are
all now honorary black people so thank
you for your
support [ __ ] you if you tried to [ __ ] me
i mean how much money they tried to
spend to get rid of this million son i
said millions but you couldn't get rid
of him
oh no
yeah can't touch this
luther what i tell you no hammer dance
come on b we won let's do it dawg no um
i i told you i don't want you doing it
wrong you got to get it right if you're
going to do it god bless america that's
right that's right santos say it no i
told you homeboy you can't touch this
hello my fellow americans with me as
always is my anger translator luther hi
now the first year of my second term has
been a challenge cluster
tonight i'd like to address the concerns
of the american people over what they
perceive as the u.s government spying on
their digital and electronic activities
man you're some deluded self-important
mother if you think we're interested in
your deviant porn watching asses i can
assure you the american people we are
not reading every individual email
rather we're searching for key words
that would indicate a threat and don't
worry everybody those key words are not
girl on girl anal squirting plopping
plopping
what the is plopping your dirty mother
these key words are being used amongst
other things to prevent terrorists from
using weapons of mass destruction not
prevent you from watching videos of ass
destruction now these policies have
already foiled numerous terrorist plots
these are not the kind of plots that
y'all are used to like when a guy comes
in the door with his penis in a pizza
box and a lady sucks on it and i assure
you that the country's gotten safer
since the end of the bush era and i
ain't talking about the president
these policies have allowed us to probe
and penetrate i know you talked about no
luther
just what i'm trying to say is that
there have been numerous terrorist cells
fingered
luther okay luther why are you trying to
undermine the president with your
juvenile sexual innuendo
the average american has nothing to fear
from these policies now if we was drone
striking perverts our country would look
like mad max beyond thunderdome right
about now i'm talking about a
post-apocalyptic nightmare
thank you and good night go to sleep
y'all
plopping oh yes sir when you
oh
y'all are some sick mother
good evening my fellow americans with me
as always is my anger translator luther
what'd it do oh
as you know
for the past six years uh
i've received my fair share of criticism
from the republican party i can't even
give malia an allowance without them
accusing me of wealth redistribution
it's all part of rough and tumble
politics i
hate
you
in recent years i've also received a
good amount of criticism from my fellow
democrats oh god this mother right here
how much oh
let's do these i'm getting i'm getting
these
not you though
i'm
now i know
the right to express one's opinion about
the powers that be
is the very thing that makes this
country great like i ain't got enough to
do we got a james bond building running
russia i got a congress full of
teabaggers the earth is burning up and
now i got to deal with all these
whiny-ass [ __ ] from my own party
some have cited my inability to make
good on my campaign promise to uh
close guantanamo bay congress shut me
down i'm a president y'all i'm a
president not a king they checked and
balanced my ass i mean god
damn
and then there are those on the left who
have criticized my continued usage of
drone strikes you know what
y'all can't have it both ways man what
do you which you can't have the soldiers
coming home and talking to moms and then
also at the same time have me killing
with in the caves
like y'all should be embracing this
technology because it's pretty amazing
man it's awesome all you do is pick up
the phone and say excuse me i like to
order two dead terrorists
could blame it's amazing i mean we can
murder people
with flying robots
it's like we're in star wars world dog
and i'm gonna fade up in this [ __ ] i
[Music]
luther
what is wrong in your head
why would you compare the president to
one of the lords of the sith
thank you and good night
[Music]
oh honey i am tired i am going to bed
good night
well
is everything okay
well
it's uh it's just that i was uh
hoping that uh
well that we could and uh i want to make
this clear
i want to be uh straightforward i want
to uh
have a
okay uh luther are you available to
translate yes ma'am
i really was hoping we could spend some
time together when is the last time we
had sex woman re-election night what
does a brother not named bill clinton
have to do to get some in this house
well you have been very busy lately
[Music]
you know what
if i could can we get your translator oh
yes certainly uh katendra
yeah honey could you please translate
well you have been very busy lately
sure
my in one of your limousines that you
can jump in and out of whenever you feel
like
i don't see you all day then you want a
booty car
i need an emotional connection
i thought this was uh romantic i'm
trying [ __ ] can't you see i'm playing
the romantic music i got the pinot and
the glasses what more do you want from
me an engraved invitation from my nuts
maybe we should make a date what am i
supposed to do jump out of my clothes
every time little bear stands at
attention you ain't my
commander-in-chief mother and my vagina
ain't some cave in the middle east you
can fly your heat-seeking missile into
whenever you feel like it
well
i didn't mean to call you but i i had
meetings all day long i'm dealing with
these mother republicans hearing no no
no all day long then i come home and
you're gonna let me get my jam out up in
here
well you know
i have had a busy day too
you act like i ain't got nothing else to
do
i got these obese [ __ ] on my
ass 24 7. what's more important you
getting your wig dipped or some
eight-year-old fat ass collapsing his
bunk bed
okay you seem to be forgetting job
number one you are my secretary of [ __ ]
get to work
you
[Music]
yes sir yeah we'll uh we'll take it from
here absolutely yes sir
oh this feels good uh mom dad i know you
already said that i can't go but can i
please go to the party tonight malia use
your
translator if you don't let me go to
this party i will get a tattoo
on my face
have fun
choices for food are respectable
[Music]
hillary mr president
it's always good to see you i've
pretended to like you for seven years
you remember my anger translator luther
good to see you too mr president my
hatred for you is a pure force of nature
that is gonna move me onward to my
destiny and this is my anger translator
savannah
i trust you've been busy bet your arms
are tired from stabbing me in the back
on the campaign trail saying you don't
like my foreign policy
you wrote the damn policy
well you know how it is to campaign for
president you know how this
works
you do whatever you got to do to get
your ass elected and right now you are
the dead skunk i gotta step over
should be smooth sailing to the
nomination even you couldn't get up
against these [ __ ] well it's too
early to say of course i got this job
locked down unless something terrible
happens like you campaigning for me
oh i got a feeling that come 2016 you
and bill will be back in the white house
yeah you gonna be busiest doing all the
work cause i know you're gonna fire them
interns what
well i appreciate having you as an ally
of course eight years ago i had a lock
on this job until you showed up out of
nowhere
and you stole it from me when you knew
damn well it was my turn you think i ate
all that standing there smiling next to
my pussy-hound husband so i could turn
around and become
of state guess again mother
you got my job and i'm gonna get it back
and it's not gonna be easy because you
screwed the poach six ways to sunday
folks just as soon vote for a scanned
possum
as a democrat but that's okay because
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna win this
election and i'm gonna bury you and
every goddamn man who ever stood in my
way savannah take it down a bit what is
wrong with you girl you are embarrassing
the future president of the united
states of america have a little class
it's always good to speak with you
hillary
you you had nasty ass [ __ ] nice to talk
to you bro
you dream still
damn some people's just too angry
evening my fellow americans every day
our citizens improve the lives of those
around them today we honor troy morrison
now troy was in geometry class when his
teacher mentioned the hypotenuse of a
triangle troy said i wish i was high on
hypotenuse
that really cracked me up and
it cracked up the rest of america too so
today i'm pleased to present troy with
the congressional comedy medal of honor
troy
on behalf of the entire country i just
want to uh
thank you for your fantastic
off-the-cuff line
you are a true comedy hero thank you sir
thank you and also mr president i have
uh something for you what's that
oh my god
yes these are sold out i haven't been
able to get my hands on one of these
thanks troy oh my goodness
good evening my fellow americans you
remember my anger translator luther why
hello now i've told luther that he can
join me for this last address but that
his being on his very best behavior is
crucial to healing the divide in this
country keep it cheer luther
go against every natural instinct in
your body
since we last spoke the country has
voted for a new president
here we go come on
come on come on really
talk about the trump
how did this happen man forget the
[ __ ]
y'all gonna vote for the dude that's
gonna make america hate again don't you
understand this is how the hunger games
starts well uh
it's true we all have to accept
that
i'm gonna have someone else calling the
shots vladimir
putin y'all you got a naked roosky on
horseback gonna be running the show
placebo russian [ __ ] it was a
close election but the people have
spoken yeah they voted for hillary
clinton but then this outdated electoral
college mumbo jumbo voodoo [ __ ] i
can't even miss that
uh it's more imperative than ever
that we move on as a country united
united in the fact that we can't [ __ ]
stand each other
even as the country adopts new policies
uh
on a trade
immigration new policy the only good
immigrant is the smoking hot white one
who plagiarizes speeches
i said [ __ ]
now i have greatly enjoyed
my time as your president except when um
you know um
let me think about limited when the
republicans wouldn't let me do [ __ ] and
then that one dude said i wasn't born
here and then you all elected him so you
know what didn't love that part so much
so pretty much the beginning middle and
the end sucked suddenly i have met with
president-elect trump and have pledged
my support
in his transition he doesn't even want
the job y'all i saw it in his eyes the
dude was shook the only reason he ran is
because his factory in china made too
many red hats
[Applause]
i assure you
that if he succeeds
we all succeed unless he succeeds with
all the [ __ ] he promised to succeed with
in that case we're [ __ ]
and now
a time cherished tradition is that the
outgoing don't say i'll go and don't say
outgoing
that's me damn it leaves the incoming
president a little note in the desk of
the oval office of course it's
completely confidential go [ __ ] yourself
until now
oh
that's my bad
so all of you out there
who are afraid that your way of life is
under attack
remember that progress
isn't always a straight line no because
sometimes it's a line that goes like
this
and it just goes straight down for four
[ __ ] years stay strong and never stop
standing up for what you believe in uh
yes i would like to book a four year
stay for five at the ice hotel in sweden
please sorry five
for both i mean y'all gonna take bo
make it six in summation
thanks america it's been real
it's been good
but it ain't been real good apparently
orange is the new black good luck with
your healthcare [ __ ] i'm out peace
i got my eye a new [ __ ] grabber
[Music]